[country rock music]
- My name is Trevor Rydell,
and welcome to my shop.
First off, my forge.
Built this myself.
And, uh, I could
take this whole thing
and rotate it this way so that
I could pass a blade down
through it for heat-treating.
My quench tank.
Like to have 9 gallons
with canola oil in it.
Kind of looks like
a stick of dynamite, I guess.
Basically a toaster oven.
This is what
I temper most of my knives in.
You know, as long as
they're not too long.
If they're too long,
I put them in my wife's oven.
And this is, uh, Mr. Squishy.
This is a 25-ton forging press.
Works pretty well.
You know, moves a lot of steel.
It's good for making Damascus.
- Hello, welcome to
beautiful north Idaho.
This is my shop. Come on in.
I'll show you what I got.
My forge.
My very first hammer from 1993.
All of my hammers have names.
My step-father's
last name on it.
He passed away recently.
Pay a little respect.
I like to be artistic
in my shop at all times,
have a little art going on.
Lots of, like,
antlers and stuff.
Got a little band saw.
I only paid
maybe $40 for this saw,
and it works fantastic.
You can do incredible work
with the bare minimum.
Here's a really nice example.
There's no power hammer
in that.
- Here's some examples
of the work I've done.
The tomahawk, I made this
maybe like six months
into bladesmithing.
You know, I had just
learned how to do it.
This is my favorite knife
I've made.
80-layer Damascus twist.
Got a brass guard on there
that I actually--
I melted down
10-millimeter casings.
This was a test knife
to see what I could do
in three hours.
Um, so just a beater, you know?
I mean, it looks goofy, but
I just wanted to see if,
you know, if I could make
a fairly long blade
in a short amount of time.
[rock music]
This is my 2x72 grinder.
I use a treadmill motor.
Good thing about
the treadmill motor is
it gives me variable speed.
And when I really want to,
this thing will, uh,
really hog some steel.
And at least it says
I burn calories while I use it.
- This is my daughter,
Isabella.
I'm not the only one
who's a blacksmith;
she makes knives
in her own right.
- I made this knife
about a year ago.
It was just my first knife.
Made out of 5160 spring steel
with a white tail deer antler?
- White tail deer, yeah.
- I'd really like to be
on the show "Forged in Fire"
so that I can beat
how well he's been doing.
- What?